Michael we understand you have a big
film coming out called this is where I
leave you and there's a lot of a-list
talent involved how did you hear about
the casting notice for this I mean like
all the other big things I've gotten to
do it was my manager got mean
appointment and I had one audition it
was very similar to spider-man actually
I had one audition with the cat like I
went into the casting director she put
me on tape sent it off to the director
and producers and a month later I got a
call saying I had booked it so it's
almost the same story I had one on tape
audition and didn't here for quite a
while you know I had also written this
one-off kind of so that's yeah that's
how I ended up booking it and then do
they tell you who's attached to it like
what type of a-list talent or you just
know it's a role for this um I mean the
info was already up on IMDb so they
didn't tell me but I had the name of the
movie and I had the name of the roles
that were in the scene that I was in so
you know I was able to do a little
sleuthing myself and figure out about it
yeah yeah I in the audition room I I
swear the reason that I booked this one
is because I put a little tag on the ad
like I improved a little tag on the end
of the scene and I feel like that was
what booked made this role because it's
just a it's a it's a raunchy
conversation back and forth the scene
it's it's um dak Shepherd was playing
like a Howard Stern type roll radio host
and I was playing his sidekick so
basically is already lagging so we were
talking about sex on the radio and I
just put on he had just he had asked me
if I won't go into that but yeah I put a
little tag a little improv tag on it and
I think that's that helps book this one
interesting so when you got the sides
for that how much effort and time
put into rehearsing that so the sides
when I got them for the audition were
four lines so not a huge you know part
memorized it pretty quickly and I mean I
it wasn't a a character that was a huge
stretch I kind of know that Artie Lange
type that laid-back kind of radio guy
you know so it didn't it didn't take all
that much I walked into the room on the
day and shawn levy the director said 2x
he was like this is ali and X was just
like it looks like an ollie I was like
there we go that's so I guess we're
ready to roll that's all the prep I
needed but nom were you listening to a
lot of Howard Stern I already was you
know so it wasn't that wasn't something
I needed to add into my regimen gotta
yeah steady diet yeah yeah pompton at
all times yeah so when you do your
little online sleuthing and you're
finding out oh look this person Tina Fey
and you know these people are involved
yeah how does that impact your audition
your your nerves your prep time I think
um um I mean I like to think that I
approach every audition throwing
everything into it but when you realize
that there's name talent like that and
that's the level project you're going in
for it does make you want it a little
more you know I probably ran the scene
an extra ten times with with a friend
you know as far as nerves I that doesn't
make me really nervous anymore because
that's what I'm dreaming of you know I
wish every movie I went in for was
starring tina fey and jason bateman you
know like that's that's what I dream who
I dream of working with the projects i
dream of being in so I don't get nervous
for that but it does it does push you
when you realize that those are the
people involved I think on set to it
pushes you because you realize you're
you're you're playing tennis with with
you know
the the the cream of the crop I was
going to say a tennis player that's
really good but I don't watch tennis so
I guess cream of the crap it is yeah do
you remember when you're on set what it
was like yeah it was great um maybe you
don't remember I don't know we were we
were shooting in a in an actual radio
station so like me and Dax were in a
soundproof room booth with a PA in there
just to cue us and so basically the
scene is him monologuing it on the radio
and me just thrown in some stuff here
and there you know so we just ran that
over and over and yeah we couldn't
really hear the director in the other
room we had to have everything come
through a PA because we were in both in
soundproof studios he was in like the
other side of the radio studio but yeah
on said it was it was fun I just kind of
tried to stay out of the way when you're
working with like the the name talent
like I've realized the for me at least
the way that it's been best working with
them is let them come to you if they
want to chat with you or if they want to
you know engage with you on a personal
level don't don't go up to them and
hound them because this is their normal
work day they're doing this every you
know so I've I normally hang back and I
everyone I've worked with so far has
been super nice and really really
gracious and nice on set so they've
always been good experiences and yeah
that one was that one was fun I don't
really everything went great I when I
showed up on set I guess I had four
lines when I booked it and I showed up
on set and the sides they gave me were
one line and I was like crestfallen you
know I was a little a little
disheartened and then I talked to my mom
and she was like well you make that one
line
a best line ever and I was like such a
mom thing to say but also very true you
know and then I got up there we did the
little read-through of it and then Sean
put me in the room and he was like all
right you know you're lying but Dex
likes to play so keep up so that was
awesome Dax Shepard is super awesome at
improv but also really like giving actor
so he included me in the scene a whole
bunch improvin back and forth it was it
was very fun yeah who'd say I mean it's
always a it's always awesome to get to
work with a great talent you know and
he's fun and it sounds like to you're
ready because that one line that you
thought you'd have turned into in the
moment just sort of a spontaneous
conference yeah and I mean we'll see
what happens cuz it most of the other
lives were improved so they might cut
them all they were like they might cut
it all you know we'll see but it was it
was fun and I do love getting to improv
that's actually a couple lines and
spider-man I got to improv and they got
kept in which was pretty cool
you